THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WILL COME TO ORDER.
GOOD MORNING, THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US FOR THIS MEETING. THE
SENATE WELCOMES THE PUBLIC IN
PERSON, AND WE ARE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN THE
STATE CAPITOL. WE HAVE ONLY
THREE BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA.
SO I ASK ALL MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE BE PRESENT IN ROOM 112
SO WE CAN ESTABLISH OUR QUORUM
AND BEGIN OUR HEARING. THESE
ITEMS ARE BEING CONSIDERED UNDER
SENATE RULE 29.10. THESE BILLS
WERE SUBSTANTIALLY AMENDED, SO
THE SENATE RULES COMMITTEE HAS
REFERRED THEM TO US TO HEAR
THOSE CHANGES. LOOKING IN OUR
CRYSTAL BALL, WE EXPECT AT LEAST
ONE MORE HEARING AFTER THIS ONE
FOR ADDITIONAL MEASURES THAT
WERE SUBSTANTIALLY AMENDED, DOES
NOT APPEAR. WE DO NOT HAVE A
QUORUM. SO WE WILL OPERATE AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE. BILL
PRESENTATIONS. OKAY. WE HAVE AN
AUTHOR HERE TODAY. WELCOME.
SENATOR NEWMAN, GO AHEAD, GET
STARTED. AND WE HAVE, BILL, SB
347. YES, MA'AM. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. AND MEMBERS, THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT SB 347, WHICH WILL HELP
STREAMLINE THE DEPLOYMENT OF NEW
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE
INFRASTRUCTURE IN CALIFORNIA BY
EXEMPTING ELECTRIC VEHICLE
CHARGING AND HYDROGEN FUELING
STATIONS FROM CALIFORNIA'S
SUBDIVISION MAP ACT. AS YOU'RE
AWARE, THE STATE HAS FULLY
COMMITTED TO THE AMBITIOUS AND
AGGRESSIVE GOAL OF MOVING BEYOND
GASOLINE POWERED AUTOMOBILES
WITH EXECUTIVE ORDER N 7920 AND
THE ADVANCED CLEAN CARS TWO
RULES REQUIRING THAT NEW
VEHICLES SOLD IN CALIFORNIA BE
ZERO EMISSION BY THE YEAR 2035.
TO SUPPORT THE EXPANDED NUMBER
OF NEW ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES,
WHICH WILL NUMBER LITERALLY IN
THE MILLIONS, THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION ESTIMATES THAT
THE STATE WILL NEED AN
ADDITIONAL 1.2 MILLION CHARGERS
OVER THE NEXT DECADE, AND
ACCORDING TO DATA FROM THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD,
THAT THE STATE'S HYDROGEN
FUELING NETWORK WILL ALSO NEED
TO BE EXPANDED BY ROUGHLY 700%
IN ORDER TO SUPPORT THE
PROJECTED NUMBER OF VEHICLES
USING HYDROGEN AS A FUEL SOURCE,
PARTICULARLY HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS.
MOVING FREIGHT, A USE CASE WHICH
EV TECHNOLOGY IS UNLIKELY TO
FULLY COVER IN THE NEAR TERM. IN
ORDER TO HAVE A CHANCE AT
SUCCESSFULLY MEETING THOSE
GOALS, WE'LL NEED TO TAKE
PROACTIVE STEPS TO ADDRESS THE
ADMINISTRATIVE BARRIERS THAT
HAVE MADE BUILDING ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE INFRASTRUCTURE IN
CALIFORNIA SUCH AN ONEROUS AND
COSTLY PROCESS. TO DATE, THIS
INCLUDES ADDRESSING THE CHRONIC
DELAYS OFTEN CAUSED BY THE
SUBDIVISION MAP ACT, WHICH
ALLOWS LOCAL OFFICIALS TO IMPOSE
VARIOUS REQUIREMENTS AS A
CONDITION OF A PARCEL SALE OR
LEASE. BECAUSE THESE
REQUIREMENTS CAN VARY
SUBSTANTIALLY ACROSS
JURISDICTIONS AND WHICH OFTEN
ONLY BECOME APPARENT WELL INTO
THE PERMITTING PROCESS, STEPS
TOWARD COMPLIANCE CAN OFTEN
IMPEDE A STATION'S DEVELOPMENT,
WITH SOME DELAYS EXTENDING AS
LONG AS SEVERAL YEARS. SB 347
WILL HELP STREAMLINE THE
CONSTRUCTION OF NEW EV CHARGING
AND HYDROGEN FUELING STATIONS BY
EXEMPTING THESE PARTICULAR USES
FROM THE SUBDIVISION MAP ACT.
SUCH A CHANGE WOULD BE FULLY IN
LINE WITH PREVIOUS SIMILAR
EXEMPTIONS, WHICH WERE GRANTED
TO SUPPORT THE DEVELOPMENT OF
OTHER CLEAN ENERGY PROJECTS TO
INCLUDE WIND, SOLAR, BIOGAS, AND
GRID BATTERY STORAGE. BY
REMOVING UNNECESSARY RED TAPE.
SB 347 WILL HELP SPEED UP THE
DEVELOPMENT OF PUBLICLY FUNDED
ZERO EMISSIONS INFRASTRUCTURE,
WHILE SENDING A STRONG MARKET
SIGNAL TO PROSPECTIVE PRIVATE
DEVELOPERS AND INVESTORS THAT
CALIFORNIA REMAINS FULLY
COMMITTED TO MEETING ITS
TRANSPORTATION DECARBONIZATION
GOALS. WITH ME TO TESTIFY TODAY
IS FAITH CONNELLY ON BEHALF OF
ONE SUCH DEVELOPER OF ZERO
EMISSIONS INFRASTRUCTURE, THE
AIR PRODUCTS CORPORATION. I AM
RESPECTFULLY ASKING FOR YOUR
VOTE TODAY. THANK YOU. THIS IS A
REMINDER, WE HAVE YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES FOR YOUR TESTIMONY THAT
THAT LONG. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS, FAITH
CONNELLY WITH VITAMIN GROUP. ON
BEHALF OF AIR PRODUCTS, I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
TODAY. I WANT TO THANK THE
CONSULTANT FOR HIS WORK ON THIS
BILL, AIR PRODUCTS HAS
ANNOUNCED, SPENDING ROUGHLY A
LARGE PORTION OF $15 BILLION IN
CALIFORNIA TO GET NEW ENERGY
PROJECTS UP BY 2027, INCLUDING A
LOT OF HYDROGEN FUELING
STATIONS. SO WE FEEL THAT SB 347
WILL ENHANCE THIS EFFORT AND
PUSH US TOWARD THAT CLOSER TO
THAT 2027 GOAL AND SO WE REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY. THANK YOU.
OKAY, WE ASK ANYONE WHO IS IN
SUPPORT, PLEASE IDENTIFY
YOURSELF AND YOUR ORGANIZATION.
GOOD MORNING MADAM. IS THIS ON?
OKAY. MADAM CHAIR AND SENATORS
ROSANNA CARVACHO ELLIOT HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
HYDROGEN COALITION. ALSO IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
YEAH JULIE MALINOWSKI, ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ELECTRIC
TRANSPORTATION COALITION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT? SEEING
NONE, DO WE HAVE ANY OPPOSITION
WITNESSES? ANYBODY WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION? NO. SEEING
NONE. COLLEAGUE I DON'T HAVE A
PLURAL COLLEAGUE. WOULD YOU LIKE
TO MAKE ANY QUESTIONS? ANY
QUESTIONS? COMMENTS. YOU HAVE
THE FLOOR. THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. I WILL
SUPPORT THE BILL. I'LL MOVE THE
BILL WHEN NECESSARY, BUT I DON'T
THINK THAT I HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
JUST YET. BUT I DO JUST
APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT YOU'RE
DOING. AND I ALSO UNDERSTAND
TAKING MASSIVE AMENDMENTS ON THE
OTHER HOUSE. SO THANK YOU FOR
BEING PATIENT. OKAY THAT'S IT.
WE CAN'T TAKE A VOTE RIGHT NOW
AND AMEND MOTION. SO WE'LL TAKE
IT UP AS SOON AS WE GET TO
QUORUM. APPRECIATE IT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ANY FINAL
REMARKS? I, SENATOR, WE HAVE TO
CLOSE FOR ME, SO THANK YOU.
OKAY. THANK YOU. OKAY WE WILL
RECESS UNTIL. UNTIL WE GET
ANOTHER. OH, WE DON'T HAVE
ANOTHER VOTE. AND YOU CAN TRY TO
GO VOTING IN LABOR. TRY TO GO
VOTE IN BETWEEN. YEAH.
YOU WANT TO MAKE A MOTION? WE'RE
STILL WAITING FOR A QUORUM.
OKAY, BUT WE CAN'T TAKE THE
MOTION WITHOUT THE COURT.
SO I'LL MOVE. SB 347 BY SENATOR
NEWMAN. OKAY, WE WILL STOP TO
ESTABLISH QUORUM. ROLL Ó
SENATORS DURAZZO HERE. DURAZZO.
PRESENT. TOYOTA SECRETO.
PRESENT. DARLEY. GLAZER SKINNER.
WAHAB WAHAB. PRESENT. WIENER
PRESENT. WIENER. PRESENT. YOU
HAVE A QUORUM. OKAY MOTION. WE
CAN MOVE. YEAH. I'LL MOVE. SB
347. OKAY MOTION. IS THAT THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS BE CONCURRED
IN SENATORS DURAZZO. DURAZZO.
Ã. SEYARTO. ALRIGHT YES.
SEYARTO. AYE. DARLEY GLAZER.
SKINNER. WAHAB. YES. WAHAB AYE.
WIENER. AYE. WIENER. AYE. 4 TO
0. OKAY. ARE WE GOING TO LEAVE?
LEAVE IT ON CALL. OKAY WE'RE IN
RECESS TO NGUYEN. OKAY. THIS IS.
THE. OKAY. WE'RE JUST IN RECESS
WAITING FOR AN AUTHOR HERE. 33
VOTES.
GOOD MORNING. ASSEMBLY MEMBER,
WE NOW HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HANEY TO PRESENT AB 3068. I
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR, AND
MEMBERS AB 3068. THE OFFICE TO
HOUSING CONVERSION ACT WILL
ACCELERATE ADAPTIVE REUSE
PROJECTS OF HISTORIC OFFICE
BUILDINGS. THIS BILL IS IN
DIRECT RESPONSE TO THE CRISIS OF
CALIFORNIA'S EMPTY DOWNTOWN
BUSINESS DISTRICTS AND THE NEED
TO CONVERT UNDERUTILIZED OFFICE
BUILDINGS WITHIN PRIME LOCATIONS
NEAR JOBS, TRANSIT BUSINESSES
INTO NEW HOUSING TO HELP OUR
DOWNTOWNS BUILD MORE HOUSING, AB
3068 WILL CREATE A PATHWAY FOR
BY RIGHT APPROVAL OF OFFICE
CONVERSION PROJECTS, ENSURING
MORE PREDICTABILITY AND FEWER
BARRIERS TO AN ALREADY DIFFICULT
BUILDING PROCESS. I WANT TO
THANK YOU AND YOUR STAFF FOR
WORKING SO CLOSELY WITH US AND
THE AMENDMENTS, THAT ARE IN THIS
BILL REFLECT AN AGREEMENT
BETWEEN LABOR GROUPS AND ENSURE
THAT PROJECTS UNDER THIS BILL
ARE SUBJECT TO FAIR AND RIGOROUS
LABOR STANDARDS. AND AGAIN, I
WANT TO THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
YOUR STAFF FOR WORKING SO
CLOSELY WITH US TO GET THIS
RIGHT. WITH ME IN SUPPORT TODAY
IS CINDY HEITZMAN FROM THE
CALIFORNIA PRESERVATION
FOUNDATION. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING,
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. I'M HERE
TODAY AS A CO-SPONSOR OF AB
3068, IN PARTNERSHIP WITH YIMBY
ACTION. AB 3068 IS A FORWARD
THINKING BILL DESIGNED TO
STREAMLINE AND FACILITATE
ADAPTIVE REUSE PROJECTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. IT ACHIEVES THESE
GOALS THROUGH STREAMLINED REVIEW
PROCESS, WHICH ALSO INCLUDES A
PROCESS FOR REVIEW OF HISTORIC
RESOURCES. THE BILL ALSO ALLOWS
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO ADOPT
SPECIFIC ORDINANCES FOR ADAPTIVE
REUSE, BUT ENSURES THAT A
DEVELOPER HAS A RIGHT TO USE AB
3068 STREAMLINED PROVISIONS. IT
PROVIDES A PATH FOR FINANCIAL
INCENTIVES, INCLUDING CERTAIN
IMPACT FEE EXCLUSIONS AND
ADAPTIVE REUSE. INCENTIVE FUNDS,
AND ALSO PROVIDES A PATH FOR
USING INCENTIVES FOR HISTORIC
REHABILITATION PROJECTS SUCH AS
FEDERAL AND STATE HISTORIC TAX
CREDITS, MILLS ACT, AND USE OF
THE CALIFORNIA HISTORICAL
BUILDING CODE. IT HAS
REQUIREMENTS FOR RESIDENTIAL USE.
AFFORDABILITY ALLOWS ADDITIONAL
RESIDENTIAL OR MIXED USE ON
ADJACENT PROPERTIES, REDUCES
PARKING REQUIREMENTS, REMOVING
ONE OF THE SIGNIFICANT BARRIERS
TO DEVELOPMENT, AND INCLUDES
LABOR STANDARDS. ADAPTIVE REUSE
IS A POWERFUL WAY TO REPURPOSE
EXISTING STRUCTURES, INCLUDING
HISTORIC BUILDINGS, INTO MUCH
NEEDED HOUSING. IN LOS ANGELES,
THE ADAPTIVE REUSE ORDINANCE HAS
CREATED OVER 12,000 HOUSING
UNITS SINCE 1999, AND A STUDY BY
THE LOS ANGELES CENTRAL CITY
ASSOCIATION ESTIMATES THAT
CONVERTING JUST 5 TO 10% OF THE
CITY'S 155,000,000FT² OF OFFICE
SPACE COULD ADD ANOTHER 8000 TO
16,000 UNITS. IN ADDITION TO
HOUSING BENEFITS, ADAPTIVE REUSE
IS ALSO A STRATEGY FOR
SUSTAINABILITY, ECONOMIC
RECOVERY, AND PRESERVING
COMMUNITY IDENTITY. BY
REPURPOSING EXISTING BUILDINGS,
WE SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE THE
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT ASSOCIATED
WITH DEMOLITION AND NEW
CONSTRUCTION. THIS REDUCES
WASTE, REDUCES OR REDUCES
RESOURCE CONSUMPTION AND CARBON
EMISSIONS. IT NOT ONLY CONSERVES
OUR ENVIRONMENT, BUT ALSO
REVITALIZES UNDERUTILIZED
SPACES, CREATING JOBS AND
ATTRACTING LOCAL INVESTMENTS. AB
3068 OFFERS A BALANCED APPROACH
TO ADDRESSING CALIFORNIA'S
URGENT NEED FOR HOUSING, WHILE
PRESERVING THE STATE'S CULTURAL
AND ARCHITECTURAL HERITAGE BY
FACILITATING ADAPTIVE WRAP IT UP,
PLEASE. THANK YOU. WILL DO, I
WANT TO THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU, ANY
MORE LEAD WITNESSES AND SUPPORT?
SEEING NONE. OTHER SUPPORT
WITNESSES. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. I'LL BE VERY BRIEF. KEITH
DUNN, WITH THE STATE BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL, WE
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S EFFORTS
TO BRING SOME CONSISTENCY TO
THIS WITH THE LABOR STANDARDS.
AND THIS IS HOUSING IS OBVIOUSLY
A CRISIS WITHIN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. SO ANYTHING WE CAN
DO TO MAKE IT EASIER TO BUILD
HOUSING WITH THOSE STANDARDS WE
GREATLY SUPPORT, WE'RE HERE
ASKING FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU.
OKAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT OF SB
368? SEEING NONE. ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION, PLEASE COME FORWARD.
GOOD MORNING, GOOD MORNING, GOOD
MORNING. MEMBERS MARK STIVERS OF
THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
PARTNERSHIP. AND MY APOLOGIES TO
THE AUTHOR THAT WE HAVEN'T BEEN
ABLE TO SUBMIT A LETTER YET.
WE'VE KNOWN ABOUT THE AMENDMENTS
FOR LESS THAN 24 HOURS, AND THE
HEARING FOR LESS THAN ONE HOUR,
WE ARE VERY APPRECIATIVE OF THE
EFFORT TO SUPPORT STREAMLINE
ADAPTIVE REUSE. THERE'S NO
ARGUMENT THERE, BUT THE RECENT
AMENDMENTS DO ADD A SKILLED AND
TRAINED WAGE REQUIREMENT, AND
THE RAND CORPORATION DID A STUDY
AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN LA AND
A SIMILAR PLA REQUIREMENT
INCREASED COSTS BY 15%. WE ARE
WORRIED THAT THE SKILLED AND
TRAINED LABOR REQUIREMENT IN
THIS BILL WILL COST MORE THAN
THE FINANCIAL BENEFITS OF THE
STREAMLINING, IN WHICH CASE IT
WON'T BE OF MUCH EFFECT IN
ACHIEVING THE BILL'S GOALS. SO
WITH THAT, WE ARE OPPOSED UNLESS
AMENDED, AND WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, CHAIR, AND
MEMBERS, MARINA ESPINOSA WITH
THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
CONSORTIUM, WE'RE ALSO OPPOSED,
UNLESS AMENDED. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ANYONE ELSE? OKAY, BRING IT
HERE TO THE DÍAS. QUESTIONS?
COMMENTS? THANK YOU, JUST AS A
BAY AREA MEMBER, I REALLY DO
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE DOING. I
KNOW THAT THIS IS KIND OF A BIG
ENDEAVOR, I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO
SEEING MORE HOUSING, HOPEFULLY
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AS A
PRIORITY, AND I'LL MOVE THE BILL.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. YES
SENATOR SERRANO, I HAVE SOME OF
THE CONCERNS I HAD BEFORE. I
STILL HAVE, REGARDING THE
CONVERSION AND USING THESE TYPES
OF PROPERTIES, I AM ALL FOR
REUSING, BUILDING THE ADAPTIVE
REUSE PROCESS, BUT IT IS A
PROCESS, AND I WANT TO MAKE SURE
WHAT IS WHAT IS INCLUDED IN THE
STREAMLINING PROCESS, BECAUSE I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
STREAMLINING, NOT SHORTCUTTING.
BECAUSE WHEN YOU'RE GOING FROM
AN ADAPTIVE REUSE OF AN
INDUSTRIAL OR A COMMERCIAL
BUILDING OR OFFICES, THEN YOU
ARE NOT, THE GOING TO A, A HIGH
OCCUPANCY, LIVING QUARTERS, MUCH
DIFFERENT IN TERMS OF HOW SMOKE
MOVES THROUGH A BUILDING, HOW
FIRE ESCAPES ARE USED, HOW
PEOPLE EGRESS AND, YOU KNOW,
ARE, YOU KNOW, THEIR ABILITY TO
GET IN AND OUT OF THE BUILDING.
IN AN EMERGENCY. AND THOSE I'M,
I DON'T WANT THOSE CAUGHT UP IN
THE STREAMLINED PROCESS BECAUSE
THERE ARE ENVIRONMENTAL CONCERNS
WHEN YOU'RE TAKING A HISTORIC
BUILDING AND YOU'RE TURNING IT
INTO A RESIDENTIAL BUILDING,
BURN RATES AND THE STRUCTURAL
ELEMENTS THAT ARE IN IT, THOSE
HAVE TO BE STUDIED. THEY HAVE TO
BE LOOKED AT. AND IF THEY'RE
CAUGHT UP IN A STREAMLINED
PROCESS, THAT ELIMINATES THAT
PART. THAT'S A CONCERN. THE
OTHER CONCERN I HAVE, AND MAYBE
YOU CAN ADDRESS IT, IS THE
ENORMOUS COST OF DOING THAT.
NOW, I REALIZE THERE'S AN
ENVIRONMENTAL SAVINGS WHEN
YOU'RE YOU DON'T HAVE TO REBUILD
A BUILDING. AND I'M I'M GOOD
WITH THAT PART. BUT, YOU KNOW,
IT THAT THOSE CONVERSIONS COST A
FORTUNE, BECAUSE YOU DO HAVE TO
REDO A LOT OF STUFF THAT'S IN
IT, INCLUDING THE WIRING, THE AC
UNITS, ALL OF THAT STUFF HAS TO
BE REDONE. AND, AND, YOU KNOW,
WE'RE ADDING COSTS WITH, WITH
THE PREVAILING WAGE REQUIREMENTS
AND THE SKILLED AND TRAINED
WORKFORCE. ALTHOUGH I WOULD
ARGUE THAT THERE'S LOTS OF
SKILLED AND TRAINED WORKERS THAT
AREN'T NECESSARILY UNION, AND
THEY COULD BE USED, BUT, YOU
KNOW, THAT'S WHAT YOU WANT TO
DO. THAT'S FINE, HOW ARE WE
GOING TO CONTAIN COSTS ON THESE
SO THAT THESE DON'T WIND UP
COSTING PEOPLE EVEN MORE, THAN
IF WE WOULD JUST START FROM
SCRATCH AND BUILD FROM DIRT?
WELL I APPRECIATE BOTH OF THOSE
QUESTIONS. AND CERTAINLY WE'VE
REALLY GRAPPLED WITH, BOTH OF
THE POINTS YOU'VE MADE, WHICH
ARE VERY WELL TAKEN. WE
OBVIOUSLY HAVE A LOT OF THESE
BUILDINGS RIGHT NOW. MANY OF
THEM ARE OLDER. MANY OF THEM NOW
ARE UNDER UTILIZED OR EMPTY. AND
SO WE'RE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
THE BEST USE. AND MANY OF THEM,
WILL NEED TO BE, TORN DOWN
COMPLETELY, ALTHOUGH MANY OF
THEM HAVE HISTORIC VALUE AS
WELL. AND SO WE DON'T WANT TO DO
THAT. THEY ADD TREMENDOUS VALUE
TO OUR DOWNTOWNS IN TERMS OF
THEIR HISTORIC VALUE AND
ARCHITECTURAL VALUE. SO WE WANT
TO STRIKE A BALANCE HERE. THERE
THIS WON'T BE AVAILABLE TO MANY
TYPES OF BUILDINGS BECAUSE OF
ALL OF THE THINGS THAT YOU'VE
JUST LAID OUT. BUT WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WHERE THERE IS
THE POSSIBILITY, EITHER BECAUSE
WE CAN MAKE HELP, MAKE IT
FINANCIALLY FEASIBLE, OR IT CAN
WORK IN TERMS OF THE NATURE OF
THE BUILDING ITSELF, THAT WE ARE
GETTING SOME OF THE BARRIERS OUT
OF THE WAY TO HELP MAKE THAT
POSSIBLE. AND SO THESE ARE SOME
OF THE THINGS THAT FOLKS WHO ARE
DOING THESE PROJECTS BROUGHT
FORWARD THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL. I
WILL SAY ON YOUR FIRST POINT
THAT ALL OF THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY AND BUILDING CODES,
WHETHER LOCAL OR STATE, WILL
STILL APPLY AND CERTAINLY THOSE
ARE SOME OF WHAT MAKE THESE
PROJECTS SO COMPLEX AND
EXPENSIVE. BUT THERE ARE A SET
OF BUILDINGS THAT ARE STILL
FEASIBLE ON THIS. AND WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE FOR AT LEAST SOME OF
THE TYPES OF APPROVAL, NOT THE
BUILDING HEALTH AND SAFETY
ASPECTS OF IT, THAT WE CAN GET
OUT OF OUR OWN WAY AND MAKE
THESE POSSIBLE AS QUICKLY AS WE
CAN. THIS ALSO INCLUDES AN
INVESTMENT INCENTIVE FUND, WHICH
WOULD HELP FINANCE SOME OF THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS, AND
THAT WILL HELP WITH SOME OF THE
ASPECTS OF TAX INCENTIVES. BUT
THERE'S A LOT MORE WORK THAT WE
HAVE TO DO ON THIS, AND I
APPRECIATE THOSE QUESTIONS. AND
CERTAINLY THERE'S A LARGER
CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW DO WE
MAKE SURE WE USE THESE BUILDINGS
BETTER, WHILE ALSO PROTECTING
HEALTH AND SAFETY. WHAT EXACTLY
IS BEING STREAMLINED? ARE WE ARE
WE EXEMPTING SEQUA. ARE WE WHAT
ARE WE DOING? IT'S SIMILAR TO
THE STREAMLINING PROVISIONS
UNDER AB 2011. WHICH, STREAMLINE
SOME OF THE REQUIREMENTS AROUND
THE ACTUAL CHANGE OF USE, BUT
NOT ANY OF THE BUILDING HEALTH
AND SAFETY CODES, BECAUSE A LOT
OF WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT IS
THE CITY PROCESS OR THE AGENCY
PROCESS. WHOEVER IS IN CHARGE OF
THESE BUILDINGS. AND WHEN YOU'RE
WHEN YOU'RE, YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT THAT PROCESS TAKING TOO
MUCH TIME, TOO MUCH STUFF,
THEY'RE ACTUALLY TRYING TO APPLY
THOSE HEALTH CODES AND ALL THOSE
OTHER THINGS. AND SO IT'S VERY,
YOU KNOW, YOU HAVE THIS MUDDLED
STREAMLINING PROCESS. YOU DON'T
KNOW WHAT STREAMLINED AND WHAT'S
NOT. AND IF THEY'RE STARTING TO
TAKE LEGAL ACTION USING YOUR
BILL TO DO IT BECAUSE THEY'RE
NOT GOING FAST ENOUGH. WELL, I
WOULD SAY WE NEED THEM TO GO
FAST, BUT ONLY THEY NEED TO GO
SLOW ENOUGH TO BE ABLE TO GET
AND MAKE SURE THAT THESE
BUILDINGS ARE SAFE TO BE
INHABITED. AND THAT'S MY BIGGEST
CONCERN IS STREAMLINING FOR A
LOT OF THINGS. YEAH, I GET IT.
THIS ONE CONCERNS ME A LOT
BECAUSE OF ALL THE THINGS THAT
SHOULDN'T BE AS STREAMLINED. IT
WOULD BE ONE OF THESE, JUST
BECAUSE OF THE LIFE. LIFE SAFETY
PART OF IT. SO ANYWAY, I
APPRECIATE YOU WORKING ON YOUR
BILL SO MUCH AND BRINGING IT
HERE TODAY. AND WITH THAT, I'LL
TURN IT BACK TO THE CHAIR. THANK
YOU. GO AHEAD. OKAY ALL RIGHT.
ANY MORE QUESTIONS? COMMENTS NØ.
ALL RIGHT. I THINK WE NEED A
MOTION A MOTION MOTION. YEAH, I
ALREADY MOVED IT. YOU ALREADY
MOVED IT. OKAY, THEN LET'S VOTE.
MOTION. IS THAT THE MEASURE? BE
RETURNED TO THE SENATE FLOOR FOR
CONSIDERATION. SENATOR DURAZZO.
DURAZZO I CIERTO. CIERTO? NO.
DOLLY GLAZER. SKINNER. WAHAB
WAHAB. AYE. WIENER. AYE. WIENER
AYE. 3 TO 1. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY, THEN WE
HAVE. YEAH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BAINES, PLEASE COME FORWARD.
GOOD MORNING. GOOD MORNING,
DOCTOR. ALL RIGHT. WELCOME,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAINES WILL
PRESENTING AB 892. GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU.
CHAIR MEMBERS. AB 892 IS A
DISTRICT BILL, WHICH CLARIFIES
THAT THE KERN COUNTY HOSPITAL
AUTHORITY AND THE KERN MEDICAL
CENTER FOUNDATION FOLLOW BEST
PRACTICES ESTABLISHED BY THE
ACCOUNTING STANDARDS BOARD AND
REQUIRES THE AUTHORITY TO
PRODUCE AND PUBLISH AN ANNUAL
AUDIT REPORT. THIS BILL ALSO
APPLIES THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
RECORDS ACT TO THE FOUNDATION.
KERN COUNTY WAS AUTHORIZED TO
CREATE THE KERN COUNTY HOSPITAL
AUTHORITY BY ENABLING
LEGISLATION PASSED IN 2014 AND
2015. THE CHANGE WAS CRITICAL TO
ENSURE THE LONG TERM FINANCIAL
HEALTH OF KERN ONLY PUBLIC
HOSPITAL. WHILE THIS NEW
GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE HAS CREATED
MANY NEW OPPORTUNITIES, IT ALSO
HAS CREATED SOME NEW CHALLENGES
ENSURING THE LONG TERM HEALTH OF
KERN MEDICAL IS OF PARTICULAR
IMPORTANCE TO ME, AS IT IS THE
HOSPITAL WHERE I COMPLETED ALL
OF MY CLINICAL ROTATIONS DURING
MEDICAL SCHOOL. IN ADDITION TO
MY RESIDENCY, IT MADE ME THE
DOCTOR THAT I AM TODAY. I KNOW
HOW IMPORTANT KERN MEDICAL IS TO
THE MOST UNDERSERVED RESIDENTS
IN KERN COUNTY. THE HOSPITAL HAS
A MEDI-CAL CASELOAD NORTH OF
70%, AND IT IS ALSO OUR REGION'S
ONLY LEVEL TWO TRAUMA CENTER.
WITH THE CLOSEST TRAUMA CENTER
BEING IN FRESNO, WHICH IS TWO
HOURS AWAY. LOSING KERN MEDICAL
WOULD MEAN LOSING LIVES AND AS A
CLOSURE, MADERA COMMUNITY
HOSPITAL HAS SHOWN US THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY CANNOT AFFORD TO
LOSE A SINGLE HOSPITAL, CLINIC
OR DOCTOR. I INTRODUCED AB 892
LAST YEAR AS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
BRING TOGETHER SEIU FIVE, TWO
ONE AND KERN MEDICAL TO ENGAGE
IN A CONSENSUS BUILDING DIALOG
ABOUT THE FUTURE OF THE
HOSPITAL. IT TOOK US NEARLY TWO
YEARS, BUT THOSE CONVERSATIONS
HAVE RESULTED IN THE AGREEMENT
THAT IS IN PRINT TODAY, WHICH
ENSURES FINANCIAL TRANSPARENCY,
ACCOUNTABILITY AND BEST
PRACTICES ARE FOLLOWED BY ONE OF
THE MOST HEALTH CARE ASSETS IN
MY DISTRICT. CURRENT MEDICAL AND
THE FOUNDATION ARE NEUTRAL ON
THE BILL, AND SEIU REMAINS IN
SUPPORT. I WANT TO THANK BOTH
STAKEHOLDERS FOR AGREEING TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS PROCESS WITH
ME TODAY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
IS BETH MALINOWSKI AND ON BEHALF
OF SEIU CALIFORNIA. GOOD
MORNING. GOOD MORNING. VERY
MUCH, WE HAVE TWO MINUTES. GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING, MADAM
CHAIR, AND MEMBERS. BETH
MALINOWSKI, SEIU CALIFORNIA,
PROUD SPONSORS OF AB 892. AS
NOTED, SEIU REPRESENTS ROUGHLY
1600 WORKERS AT CA HEALTHCARE
WORKERS, INCLUDING PHYSICIAN
RESIDENTS, AS NOTED, THE
AUTHORITY IS ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL
TO THE HEALTH OF KERN COUNTY AND
THE SURROUNDING COUNTIES THAT
THEY SERVE. AND THE YEARS SINCE
THE AUTHORITY WAS ESTABLISHED
AND THE BOARD SEATED, WE HAVE
STARTED TO SEE WHERE
IMPROVEMENTS COULD BE MADE. AND
IT'S WITH THAT IN MIND THAT WE
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY LAST YEAR TO
APPROACH ASSEMBLYMEMBER DOCTOR
BAYNES TO INTRODUCE THIS BILL,
AB 892, AND START A
CONVERSATION, AS SHE NOTED, WE
KNEW WE COULD DO BETTER FOR THIS
COMMUNITY. WE'RE GRATEFUL TO THE
MEMBER AND FOR THE STAFF THAT
HAVE WORKED TIRELESSLY WITH US.
AND AS NOTED, THE BILL AS
INTRODUCED AND AS MANY OF YOU
SAW IN HEARINGS LAST SUMMER, WAS
MUCH BROADER THAN THE BILL
BEFORE YOU TODAY. THE GOOD NEWS
IS DISCUSSIONS THAT START IN
SACRAMENTO LAST SUMMER LED TO
LOCAL IMPROVEMENTS ON SOME
MATTERS, INCLUDING THE
APPLICATION OF MBBA TO A UNIT OF
OUTPATIENT HEALTH CARE WORKERS.
AS WE REFLECTED ON WHERE
POSITIVE CHANGE HAS BEEN SEEN,
TOOK INTO CONSIDERATION
POTENTIAL OPAQUENESS OF THE
EARLIER ALL ENTITIES LANGUAGE
INCLUDED IN THE INTRODUCED BILL,
WHICH, BEFORE YOU TODAY IS A FAR
NARROWER BILL FOCUSED ON
FINANCIAL TRANSPARENCY.
SPECIFICALLY, IT ADDRESSES
PROVISIONS OF CPRA AND MAKING
SURE THEY ARE APPLIED NOT ONLY
TO THE RECORDS OF THE AUTHORITY,
BUT ALSO THE MEDICAL FOUNDATION,
MAKING SURE BOTH CA AND THE
FOUNDATION ARE MAINTAINING
FINANCIAL RECORDS IN KEEPING
WITH GASBY AND FASB, TWO KIND OF
ACCOUNTING STANDARDS BOARDS
COMPLETING ANNUAL AUDITS OVER AT
THE AUTHORITY. THAT'S INCLUSIVE
OF THE FOUNDATION THAT IS SEEN
AS A COMPONENT UNIT IN THIS
CASE, AND MAKING SURE THOSE
AUDITS ARE MADE PUBLIC, AGAIN, I
JUST WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE HEALTH
CARE WORKERS ARE INCREDIBLY
COMMITTED TO THE QUALITY CARE.
THEY'RE KNOWING THAT GREATER
FINANCIAL TRANSPARENCY WILL
IMPROVE FINANCIAL PRACTICES WITH
THE AUTHORITY AND ULTIMATELY
HELP PATIENT CARE. LASTLY, I DO
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THIS
BILL ONLY MODERNIZES ENABLING
STATUTE RELATING SPECIFICALLY TO
THIS AUTHORITY AND WHILE Dð THE
RELATIONSHIP OF THE AUTHORITY
AND THE NONPROFIT FOUNDATION
ARGUES FOR THE APPLICATION OF
CPRA TO THE FOUNDATION, WE IN NO
WAY ARE LOOKING TO, OR SHOULD WE
BE INTERPRETING THIS BILL TO
MAKE ANY SORT OF GENERAL POLICY
OR STANCE ON THE APPLICATION OF
CPRA MORE BROADLY TO NONPROFITS?
I JUST WANT TO BE CLEAR ABOUT
THAT IN MY CLOSING AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY. THANK YOU. GREAT.
THANK YOU. ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT
OF AB 892? OKAY. ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB 892? SEEING
NONE, WE'LL BRING THE QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS HERE FROM OUR
MEMBERS, YES, SENATOR. THANK YOU,
SO I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT I DO
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK ON THIS, I
ALSO UNDERSTAND THE NEED,
ESPECIALLY FOR SAFETY NET
HOSPITAL IN A MORE RURAL AREA.
WE HAVE SAFETY NET HOSPITAL IN
MY DISTRICT, AND IT ALWAYS SEEMS
TO BE IN THE RED. AND, YOU KNOW,
THEY SAY THAT THEY CHANGED
LEADERSHIP, BUT IT'S SOMETIMES
THE SAME TYPE OF PEOPLE, AND I
JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT AS A
PERSON WHO DOES SUPPORT
NONPROFITS, I WOULD NEVER
SUPPORT THIS EFFORT WHEN IT IS
ABOUT OTHER NONPROFITS. AND THE
REASON FOR THAT IS BECAUSE
THERE'S A LOT OF COMMUNITY
NONPROFITS THAT ARE WAY TOO
SMALL, THAT COULD NOT COMPLY,
WOULDN'T EVEN REALLY NECESSARILY
UNDERSTAND EXACTLY WHAT WHAT
THIS IS REQUIRING OF THEM. SO IN
REGARDS TO A STATE, YOU KNOW,
FACILITATED A HOSPITAL AND SO
FORTH, WHERE LIVES ARE IMPORTANT
AND OBVIOUSLY, THE CASH FLOW IS
VERY MUCH LINKED TO THE
STABILITY OF THAT HOSPITAL. I
FULLY SUPPORT IT, BUT I JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
NOT GOING TO BE EXPANDING IT. SO
I APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS
THERE. I'M HAPPY TO MOVE THE
BILL. THANK YOU. I DO HAVE A
QUESTION, RELATED TO THAT, IF
YOU COULD JUST, TALK A LITTLE
BIT MORE ABOUT SUBJECTING A
PRIVATE NONPROFIT, TO THE PUBLIC
RECORDS ACT AND JUST FURTHER
THOUGHTS, WHAT TRIGGERED IT? WHY
DO YOU THINK THAT'S SO
IMPORTANT? SO I WANT TO BE CLEAR
THAT THIS IN NO WAY DO I ATTEND
IS EXACTLY WHAT SENATOR WAHAB
SAID. TO SET A STATEWIDE
PRECEDENT WITH THIS BILL FOR ALL
NONPROFITS, I WANT TO MAKE THAT
VERY, VERY CLEAR. THE KERN
HOSPITAL AUTHORITY AND ITS
FOUNDATION REPRESENT A VERY
UNIQUE OPERATING STRUCTURE THAT
IS SHARED BY VERY FEW OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS. IN CURRENT LAW,
WE DO SEE SOME LIMITED EXAMPLES
OF THE CPR BEING APPLIED TO THE
FOUNDATION THAT SUPPORTS THE
ALAMEDA HOSPITAL AUTHORITY, AS
WELL AS NONPROFITS THAT OPERATE
CHARTER SCHOOLS AND PARTNERS
WITH TRANSIT AGENCIES. SO IN ALL
OF THESE CASES, THOSE ARE UNIQUE
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT HAVE LED TO
THE APPLICATION OF THE CPR. THAT
IS ALSO THE CASE WITH THIS BILL
WHERE KERN COUNTY HOSPITAL
AUTHORITY WAS CREATED BY SPECIAL
STATUTE IN 2014 AND THE
FOUNDATION ALREADY EXISTED FROM
BEFORE, WHEN THE HOSPITAL WAS
OPERATED BY THE COUNTY. SO THE
KERN MEDICAL FOUNDATION ITSELF
DOES NOT OPPOSE THIS BILL AND
WAS INVOLVED IN THE NEGOTIATION
AND DRAFTING OF THIS BILL AS
WELL. AND I'M HAPPY, SENATOR, TO
ADD IN SOME MORE SPECIFICS IN
TERMS OF THE KERN COUNTY
HOSPITAL AUTHORITY, THE
FOUNDATION AND THE TREATMENT OF
PUBLIC DOLLARS, AND WHY, WE JUST
THINK IT IS IN THE BEST INTEREST
OF THE COMMUNITY TO MAKE SURE
THAT CPR IS BEING APPLIED
EQUALLY ACROSS BOTH ENTITIES. SO
IN PARTICULAR, WE SEE ACTUALLY
SIGNIFICANT FUNDS, BOTH FROM
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES, OUR STATE'S MEDICAID
AGENCY, ARE MOVING BETWEEN THESE
TWO ENTITIES AS WELL AS HFA
GRANTS THAT, AS FOLKS ARE AWARE,
CAN BE INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
LOCALLY TO ADDRESSING FACILITY
NEEDS, WE ARE AWARE OF AT LEAST
ONE CASE WHERE TRAFFIC GRANT
FUNDS WERE GIVEN A NUMBER OF
YEARS AGO TO HELP SUPPORT
IMPROVEMENTS ON THE PEDIATRIC
SIDE OF CARE, INCLUDING THE
ESTABLISHMENT, I BELIEVE, OF A
PEDIATRIC ER. FROM THE BEST OF
OUR KNOWLEDGE, LOCALLY, IT'S
UNCLEAR KIND OF HOW THOSE
DOLLARS HAVE BEEN UTILIZED
BECAUSE THE PROJECT HAS STILL
NOT BEEN COMPLETED, EVEN THOUGH
THE FUNDS WERE ALLOCATED MANY
YEARS AGO. SO THIS IS ONE OF ONE
EXAMPLE I CAN OFFER YOU AS TO
WHY WE THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
CPR IS BEING APPLIED NOT JUST TO
THE AUTHORITY, BUT ALSO TO THE
FOUNDATION. OKAY THANK YOU. ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS?
SEEING NONE, MOTION BY SENATOR
WAHAB, SHOULD WE CLOSE? DID YOU
WANT TO SAY FINAL VOTE? OKAY.
THANK YOU. MOTION. IS THAT THE
MEASURE BE RETURNED TO THE
SENATE FLOOR FOR CONSIDERATION.
SENATOR DURAZZO, I DURAZZO I
CIERTO. CIERTO? NO DOLLY.
GLASER. SKINNER. SKINNER. AYE.
WAHAB. WAHAB. AYE WIENER.
WIENER. AYE. 4 TO 1. CLOSE THE
VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, ASSEMBLY MEMBER. OKAY. WE
HAVE. THAT'S IT FOR ON CALL. I
THINK. SHOULD WE GO BACK? GO
BACK TO. WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK
TO SB 347. I'M SO SICK AND TIRED.
UCBCP TÍNH. OKAY YES. ITEM ONE
SB 347. WE'LL FINISH ON THE ROLL
THE VOTES MOTION THAT THE
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS BE CONCURRED IN
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
SENATORS DOLLY GLAZER. SKINNER
AYE. SKINNER. AYE 5 TO 0. OKAY
CLOSE. CLOSE THE ROLL, WE GO ON
TO ITEM TWO, AB. OH, THAT ONE'S
DONE. ALL RIGHT, OUT OF ORDER.
OKAY. WE'LL GO TO ITEM THREE AB
3068. MOTION. IS THAT THE
MEASURE BE RETURNED TO THE
SENATE FLOOR FOR CONSIDERATION.
CURRENT VOTE IS 3 TO 1 WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. SENATORS DOLLY
GLAZER. SKINNER HI. SKINNER.
AYE. 4 TO 1. CLOSE THE ROLL.
CLOSE THE ROLL AND THAT'S IT.
THAT'S IT. OKAY. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU TO EVERYBODY WHO
PARTICIPATED TODAY IN PUBLIC
TESTIMONY, YOU'RE ALSO WELCOME
TO SUBMIT YOUR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE SENATE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE. THEY'RE
VERY IMPORTANT TO US. WE WANT TO
INCLUDE THEM IN OUR TESTIMONY
AND OUR OUR OFFICIAL RECORDS.
WITH THAT, WE HAVE CONCLUDED THE
AGENDA. SENATE COMMITTEE ON
LOCAL GOVERNMENT IS ADJOURNED.
THANK YOU.